let's do another problem with repeated
roots so let's say our differential
equation is the second derivative of Y
minus the first derivative plus 0.25
that's what's written here 0.25 y is
equal to zero
and they've actually given us some
initial conditions they said that y 0 is
equal to 2 and Y prime of 0 is equal to
1/3 so like we've done in every one of
these constant coefficient linear second
order homogeneous differential equations
let's get the characteristic equation
so that's R squared minus minus R plus
0.25 or we could even call it plus point
1/4 so let's see when I just inspecting
this it always confuses me when I have
fractions so it becomes very hard to
factor so let's just do the quadratic
formula so the roots of this are going
to be R is equal to negative B well B is
negative 1 so negative B is going to be
1 plus or minus the square root of B
squared B is negative 1 so that squared
is 1 minus 4 times a which is 1 times C
well 4 times 1 times 0.25 that's that's
one uh-huh so notice then when you have
a repeated root this under the square
root becomes 0 that makes sense because
it's this plus or minus in the quadratic
formula that gives you two roots whether
they be real or complex but if the
square root is 0 you're adding plus or
minus 0 and you're only left with one
root anyway we're not done yet
and what's the denominator of the
quadratic equation to a so a is 1 so
over 2 so our one repeated root is 1
plus or minus 0 over 2 or it equals 1/2
and like we learned in the in the last
in the last video you might just say oh
well maybe the solution is just Y is
equal to C e to the one-half
Exce but like we pointed out last time
you have to initial conditions and this
solution is not general enough for two
initial conditions and then last time we
said okay this isn't general enough
maybe some solution that was you know
some function of x times e to the
one-half X maybe that would be our
solution we said it turns out it is and
so that more general solution that we
found that we figured out that V of X is
actually equal to some constant plus x
times some other constant so our more
general solution is y is equal to c1
times e to the 1/2 X plus c2 times X e
to the one-half X forgot the X here they
draw a line here so you don't get
confused anyway that's the reasoning
that's how we came up with this thing
but and and it is good to know because
later on when you want to know more
theory of differential equations and
that's really the whole point about
learning this if your whole goal isn't
just to pass an exam it's good to know
but when you're actually solving these
you could just kind of know the template
if I have a repeated root well I just
put that repeated root twice and one of
them gets an X in front of it and they
have two constants but anyway this is
our general solution and now we can use
our initial conditions to solve for c1
and c2 so let's just figure out the
derivative of this first so it becomes
easy to substitute in for c2 so y Y
prime is equal to let's see it's equal
to 1/2 C 1 e to the 1/2 X plus now this
becomes a little bit more comfortable
here so let's see plus c2 times
derivative of X is 1 times e to the 1/2
X that's the product rule plus the
derivative of e to the 1/2 x times X so
that's 1/2 X e to the 1/2
X or we can write I don't want to lose
this stuff up here we can write that the
it equals let's see I have see if I can
I have one half so I have C two times e
to the one-half X and I have one half
times C one e to the one-half X so I
could say it's equal to e to the one
half x times C 1 over 2 that's that plus
C 2 that takes care of these two terms
plus C 2 over 2x e to the one-half X and
now let's use our initial conditions let
me actually clear up some space because
I think it's nice to have our initial
conditions up here so we can see them so
let me delete all this stuff here that
hopefully make sense to you by now we
know the characteristic equation we
figured out the general so look I don't
want to erase our initial conditions we
figured out the general solution was
this I'll keep our general solution
there and so now we just substitute our
initial conditions into our into our
general solution and the derivative of
the general solution and and hopefully
we can get meaningful answers so
substituting into our general solution Y
of 0 is equal to 2 so Y is equal to 2
when X is equal to 0 so C 1 when X is
equal to 0 all the e terms become 1
right this one will become 1 and then
notice we have an x e to the 0 so now
this X is 0 so this whole term is going
to be equal to 0 so we're done C 1 is
equal to 2 that was pretty
straightforward this X actually made it
a lot easier so C 1 is equal to 2 and
now we can use the derivative so let's
see this is this is the first derivative
so let's see and I'll substitute C 2 C 1
in there so we can just solve for C 2 so
our first derivative is Y prime is equal
to let's see see C 1 1 half plus C 2 so
it's
it's well I'll write this first it's
equal to 2 over 2 so it's 1 plus C 2
times e to the 1/2 X plus C 2 over 2
times X e to the 1/2 X there was an X
here so when we when X is equal to 0 Y
prime is equal to 1/3 so 1/3 is equal to
well X is equal to 0 this will be 1 so
it's equal to 1 plus C 2 and then this
term when X is equal 0 this whole thing
becomes 0 right because this X just
cancels out the whole thing it
multiplied by 0 you get 0 so then we get
1/3 is equal to 1 plus C 2 or that C 2
is equal to 1/3 minus 1 is equal to
minus 2/3 and now we have our particular
solution and let me write it down and
put a box around it so this was our
general solution our particular solution
given these initial conditions for this
repeated root problem is y is equal to
c1 we figure that out to be 2 fairly
quickly 2 e to the 1/2 X plus C 2 C 2 is
minus 2/3 so minus 2/3 X e to the 1/2 X
and we are done
there is our particular solution so once
again kind of the proof of how do you
get to this you know why is there this X
in there and it wasn't a proof it was
really more of just to show you the
intuition of where that came from and it
did introduce you to a method called
reduction of order to figure out what
that function V was which ended up just
being you know c1 plus c2 times X but
all of that can be pretty complicated
but you see that once you know the
pattern once you you know that this is
going to be the general solution they're
pretty easy to solve characteristic
equation get your general solution
figure out the derivative of the general
solution and then substitute your
initial conditions to solve for your
constants and you're done anyway I'll
see you in the next video and actually
we're going to start solving
non-homogeneous
differential equations see you soon